so I'm reading an article this weekend
somebody tweeted it and I think I click
the link through or maybe a friend of
mine sent me the link I don't remember
that the that the rich are getting
richer and the poor are getting poorer
now you've heard that your whole life
right and but here let me help you with
this because I just think it's
interesting how people misinterpret data
so um because there's actually some
friends of mine they wrote the article
and they were just wrong um here's what
they were talking about they were
talking about that the number of people
that are a millionaire in the u.s. just
just the other day a fresh study came
out that of course in 2008 with the
stock market drop and with us you know
that we lost a lot of millionaires
meaning the millionaires weren't worth a
million anymore and because a lot of
them had their money in stock and so now
with the stock market in the real estate
market both returning a lot of those
have returns so there's there's a just
under nine million millionaires in the
u.s. right now just under nine million
millionaires and that's up almost two
million now let me help you with this if
you had seven million millionaires and
now you have nine million millionaires
don't you have more millionaires yum
yeah
so that means someone that wasn't a
millionaire is now a millionaire so that
means the poor are getting richer that
means people that weren't millionaires
before have become millionaires the
little man has gotten ahead it was
official the data was there but the
headline read rich get richer poor get
poorer when in fact we have more people
succeeding at building wealth than at
any time in history more people have
become wealthy that doesn't mean that
more people have become poor it means
more people became richer that doesn't
mean
that if there's more people that are
wealthy that means there's fewer people
that aren't hello is this is helpful so
the rich didn't get richer in the poor
get poorer some of the poor got richer
that's what we're saying or at least the
upper middle class got richer right if
you want to call them rich already I
guess you could so kind of a pet peeve
of mine but it's just good news that the
little man out there is getting ahead
hello your 401 K is looking like a 401 K
again instead of a 201 K the value of
your home is up again you're winning out
there people are opening and growing
businesses people are succeeding at
their jobs and saving like they've never
done before more people have built
wealth in the last couple of years and
entered that status nine million almost
now millionaires entered that level now
you might be shocked to know that most
millionaires don't even feel like
they're a millionaire because people
forget what a millionaire is even the
president sometimes miss quotes this and
certainly a lot of the politicians do
they've told you that a millionaire is
someone who makes an income of million
dollars a year and that's actually not
true that's not what a million areas you
need to look up your basic Webster's
definition of things a millionaire is
someone who has a net worth of 1 million
dollars your net worth is composed of
what you own minus what you owe equals
your net worth what you own add up all
the things you own your mutual funds or
401 K your investments your home cash in
the bank gold coins bullets whatever it
is you own - any debt you have of any
kind equals your net worth so your
assets minus your liabilities equals
your net worth when you have 1 million
dollars in the net worth column you are
a millionaire and so if you don't have
any debt and you have a paid-for
$700,000 house and $500,000 near 401
you have a net worth on those two things
alone of $1,200,000 you're a millionaire
and there's a lot of people with a nice
home and a nice retirement savings that
have been saving for 25 and 30 years and
there's 65 and there's 70 years old and
there's nine million people that are now
millionaires which means they have a net
worth of a million dollars and if we
have more of those than we had before
that means we have fewer people who
aren't prospering than we used to have
unless we imported some poor people from
somewhere and we probably did that too
but it's a side issue I guess so let me
help you with this more millionaires
does not mean the rich got richer and
the poor got poorer
it means someone that wasn't rich before
got richer and so it doesn't fall into
the wealth inequality wealth inequality
inequality movement people the wimps the
wim peas it doesn't follow into euro it
doesn't fall into your arguments so
those evil people have gone out there
saved their money worked hard built
businesses served someone and and now
have a net worth when we add up their
401k in their home in their cash and
their other assets - any liabilities
they have is equal 1 million dollars
that's good news to hear that there's
more of them than there used to be I'd
like to take credit for some of that I
see your hand out there I see you I see
you yes I see you I'll take credit for a
couple of those not all 2 million of
them but a couple of them a couple of
them yeah they got out of that and when
they got out of that they had money when
they had money they invested it and
saved it and then ended up with a
million dollar net worth woohoo yay
maybe they were just smart enough to
start saving for their retirement when
they were 20 another 60 and they got
three million dollars two million
dollars in their
401k let's say that makes you evil now
of course you've done something wrong
and should be ashamed of yourself you
should hang your head in sorrow for
having been such a low-rent person as to
build wealth see that's kind of
backwards - to call someone to built
wealth low rent that's kind of they
really actually high rent part things so
anytime you read a headline that's
saying there's more wealthy people
you're supposed to cheer because it
means you got a shot baby you get to be
one maybe later - keep doing smart stuff
because wealthy people can help other
people more because they have money to
do it with that's weird
you